everyone my name is Jesse from the
BuzzFeed food team and today I'm gonna
cook it up for famous celebrity pancake
recipes to see which one is actually the
best I have recipes lined up from Gordon
Ramsay Ina Garten Chrissy Teigen and for
a little bit fun I even have a recipe
from the rock I measure all the
ingredients precisely to make everything
fair I picked my winner but I got three
of my friends to pick their winners in a
blind taste test to see which one is
actually the best so let's get cooking
Gordon gets all fancy and separates his
egg whites from the yolks and whips them
until foamy this is just incorporate air
into the pancakes to make them nice and
fluffy and he must be cooking for a
crowd she used an entire liter of milk 8
teaspoons of baking powder and 640 grams
of flour which if you're not familiar is
a [ __ ] ton of flour after that he mixes
all the remaining ingredients together
in a separate bowl he folds the whites
back into that mixture and that batter
is good to go
he cooks them in a buttered skillet
until brown but no lamb sauce this time
I feel like these celebrities have their
coloration of Pancakes down pat a little
thinner than I'm used to they've missed
a few ingredients I love it it's like
Sunday morning these are Gordon Ramsay's
I would expect any recipe of his to be
pretty top-notch and I have to say that
he's working up next is ina gardens
recipe from banana sour cream pancakes
she starts by sifting all her and dry
ingredients together in one ball and
mixes all her wet ingredients and
another this includes eggs lemon zest
good vanilla her secret ingredient sour
cream
then milk she serves that until smooth
and then adds that back into her dry
mixer and mixes that up until smooth she
heats up a skillet with butter add the
batter to that and tops each pancake
with one tablespoon of diced bananas
flip them then serve them with butter
even more bananas and garnish with maple
syrup ooh these look like Instagram a
bowl like brunch pancakes that you pay
like $20 for mmm never having any
pancakes before but this takes like
banana pudding for breakfast but it's
like the banana provides an interesting
contrast in taste and texture which is
really nice whoever made this is
heaven-sent the pointed at myself I wish
I liked it more up next is Chrissy
Teigen with a recipe for her Dutch baby
pancake Chrissy goes super simple and
just dumps everything straight into a
blender to make her batter she blends
that up until smooth and then dumps it
directly into a heated cast-iron skillet
with two tablespoons of butter she
transfers that thun oven let's a bake
for about 17 minutes that comes out
looking like this crazy crackly
weird-looking thing and she finishes it
with butter maple syrup and a generous
dusting of powdered sugar so Chrissy
must have a sweet tooth it looks kind of
like an elephant ear if you look at it
it looks like almost like gelatinous in
the middle this is like a french toast
pancake you can taste a lot of egg in it
which I'm not used to in pancakes it's
not necessarily a bad thing it's just
really different this is Chrissy Teigen
okay I like it I love it
Dwayne the rock Johnson uses traditional
pancake mix he posted his video on
Instagram so I tried to mimic it as
closely as possible
he has milk chocolate chips not
semi-sweet is explained the sweet
chocolate was his nickname at University
of Miami he cooked someone a stovetop
flips him and as if chocolate isn't
enough for this guy he finishes them
with maple syrup and whipped cream this
would certainly make the perfect cheat
day Mia so these look like IHOP birthday
pancakes this is really good this is it
this is the [ __ ] this is my damn the
chocolate chips are like super glue on
the inside the dough is perfect it's not
too eggy these are the rocks pancakes I
smell what The Rock is cooking I'm so
ashamed
whatever I blow out a side minute my
favorite celebrity pancake recipe is the
rock and honestly because his has
chocolate chips that's it I would say my
favorite of the celebrity pancake
recipes was ina Gardens hers had a
really great taste with the bananas and
also the bananas in the pancakes
themselves provided a nice change in
texture my favorite celebrity recipe is
definitely the rock I mean I don't know
how this fluffy monster made this
beautiful combination but I think it has
the right amount of chocolate it has the
right amount of pancake and it has the
right amount of sweetness and it's still
fluffy which is still
so turns out the rock is the best
celebrity of pancake recipe solos are so
damn those pancakes are good which
celebrity recipe do you want to see next
let us know in the comments below
[Music]